there have been 355 mass shootings this
year few days ago Colorado Springs
before that Roseburg Oregon
before that Chattanooga Tennessee and on
and on it goes the San Bernardino
shooting was the 350 fifth mass shooting
this year two of those done by some more
sick and deranged individuals but this
time by brown-skinned people who
ascribed to being Muslims who obviously
according to the majority mainstream
consensus of Muslims worldwide and the
Muslim American community and Islamic
scholarship all agree that they were in
no way acting in accordance with Islam
and the Islamic teachings of peace mercy
and justice it would be very racist and
bigoted to conveniently forget about the
other 353 evil acts of terrorism that
were perpetuated this year their
religion or ideology wasn't really even
brought up at all and now to
conveniently only focus on these
deranged sick persons and to use this
opportunity to try to defame Muslims in
Islam again terrorism extremism mass
shooting attacks on innocent people etc
have nothing to do with Islam because
Islam condemns it and does it jihad
against it now anyone who's read the
Complete Idiot's Guide to Islam can tell
you that it's very malicious to try and
use this opportunity to attack Islam and
Muslims only the Sikh that hearts would
do that keep your heart alive and away
from joining the hate parade
help be part of the solution and not the
problem
help spread peace understanding and love
not hate our heart goes out to the
families and all the victims of such
evil crimes